let's get to questions for the week
first one's from Angela hey David could
a socially liberal Republican win the
Republican presidential primary I
actually think the answer over time is
going to be yes on this and there's a
couple different reasons why number one
when you say socially liberal do you
mean someone who is actually socially
liberal or merely someone sort of
willing to say that they're willing to
listen to the other side and what I mean
by that is what we've seen under the
Donald Trump campaign and Donald Trump
presidency is that Donald Trump really
is I don't know if we want to say
socially liberal but certainly socially
libertarian right his entire life Trump
didn't care about abortion in fact we
may soon find out that Trump even has a
personal history with the medical
procedure called abortion don't know but
wouldn't be surprised given all the
stories that have been coming out about
Donald Trump Donald Trump was not a
religious man growing up although now he
claims that the Bible is his second
favorite book or first favorite book
with his own book being the second
favorite book whatever so number one I
actually think that increasingly for the
Republican Party positions on social
issues don't so much matter as long as
the candidate can draw a line to
evangelical voters because evangelical
voters hold a very very important
position in the Republican Party but
there's another issue that I think is
relevant here which is that the country
has been moving to the left the country
has been moving to the left on almost I
can't think of any social issue on which
the country has moved to the right
whether it's gay rights support for
abortion transgender rights and stuff
like bathroom bills and that sort of
thing
religion in schools which starts to
become it goes beyond just being a
social issue the country has been moving
to the left now the reason that you see
Republican candidates and elected
officials still harp on these social
issues from a very ideological often
religious right-wing perspective is that
a lot of the donors and the
organizations that donate a lot of money
still want to see that right-wing social
position and thus even if it doesn't
reflect the views of the average
consumer
- n't even in red states you still see a
lot of money being raised by taking
those hardline ideological often
religious religious zealotry type
positions over time my guess is that
social issues are going to be become
much more sort of moderate in total in
the country and moving to the left where
it won't even really be to the advantage
of a candidate to talk about something
like gay rights the longer things go
with abortion being legal and the
realization that legal and safe access
to abortion is actually something that's
very good for society over the long term
I think you will see social issues sort
of recede from the dialog even within
the Republican Party and that yeah a
socially liberal Republican will at some
point win the Republican presidential
primary the question will be at the time
that they are able to win the Republican
primary will they still be considered
socially liberal or will have will the
entire country have moved to the left
further that they will still appear to
be conservative compared to whatever the
social positions are of the Democratic
or other left-wing party at the time
yeah I think by and large a socially
liberal Republican could win their
presidential primary but you have to
break it down by issue so I think
someone who's in favor of gay marriage
or marijuana legalization or euthanasia
could win the Republican Party yeah
because those issues seems to be fading
away they're not you know in the public
spotlight as much as they used to be
people were coming around to it but
there is one exception I think the one
issue that you'd have to be steadfast on
is your opposition to abortion I think
you have to draw that line to
evangelicals and they're not gonna back
someone who's pro-choice I think that
what you're saying is true right now I
don't see although you know I even still
think there could be exceptions now
because there are Republicans who take
positions like I'm okay I'm against late
term abortions and I want to put in
place things like mandatory waiting
periods and
may probably not transvaginal
ultrasounds if someone is this moderate
but they are okay with abortions before
X number of weeks even even unlike a
personal level or something like that so
I still think it's moderating but I
think you're right with that right now
that would be the toughest pill to
swallow for right-wing voters but 10
years from now that could be very very
different